ظروف الحياه في معسكر دويا في محافظه
الكرمك الحدوديه مع اثيوبيا ليست بالرقه
حتى لو اشرقت الشمس
اسره زينب عادت لتويها طوعا الى هذه
الربوع بعد سنوات طويله من اللجوء في
الجانب الاثيوبي
عربي
ناكل الايادي
العيال هناك ما في حاجه ياكله
الناس هنا ينتظرون الفرجه وحسب
اما عائشه ورفيقتها فيتخبدن مشاقه الذهاب
والعوده لمسافات طويله للحصول على ما
ينهيك اجسادهن قبل ان يروينا عطش باقي
افراد اسرهن
في البيت
يستقبل هذا المعسكر يوميا وسرا جديدا من
اللاجئين العائدين من اثيوبيا
الجديده يبدا من تحت الاشجار لمن يريد ان
يسمع استغاثتهم
2021 حتى الان ما في دكتور نهائي لما في
دكتور في واحد مدرب اسعافات الاوليه يعني
يوم يمشي الدقيقه كلها
افرازات الحرب التي دارت في الاقليم تبدو
جليه عند تجوالنا في محافظه الكرمك فالطرق
الواعره الرابطه بين محافظات الاقليم هي
واحده من التحديات التي تواجه تقديم
الخدمات الانسانيه للعائدين وكانهم
يتورثون الشقاء جيلا بعد جيل فبعد سنوات
من المعاناه والحرمان في رحله لجوء دامت
عقودا يواجه هؤلاء الى ديارهم واقعا لا
يقل مراره في ظل عجز السلطات عن توفير
الحد الادنى من الخدمه حيث الجزيره محافظه
القربنك الازرق